الى ملف اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب اذا من
السودان باتجاه جده نذهب الى هناك الان
حيث وصلت طائره اجلاء هنديه الان من
السودان الى قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
هنصفيان معنا من هناك هاني المزيد عن وصول
هذه الطائره الجديده
نعم اهلا صهيب اذا طائره اجلاء جديده
عسكريه هنديه تصل هذه اللحظات الى قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه
على متنها اكثر من مئه
وعشرين شخص
هذه اللحظات الاولى الان التي يتم فيها
نزول الرعايه وهم جميعهم من الجنسيه
الهنديه
باستثناء ثلاثه اشخاص هم من الجنسيه
السودانيه يعملون في القنصليه الفرنسيه
طبعا الرعايه جميعهم هم بحاله صحيه جيده
وايضا تم دخول الطاقم الطبيه قبل قليل الى
داخل الطائره ونشاهد يعني الفرحه على وجوه
يعني هؤلاء الواصلين الى جده الان من
السودان
صحيح نعم هي فرحه سعاده ومع فرحه من
تاثيرات ايضا ومشاهد قد شاهدوها في في
هناك في السودان طبعا هناك بعض
المجندات السعوديات في القوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه يقوم بترحيبهم واعطائهم
ايضا بعض الورود وايضا بعض الحلوى طبعا في
مقدمه استقبال الرعايه هو وزير الدوله
للشؤون الخارجيه الهنديه وبجانبه قائد
قطاع او قائد قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
اللواء عبد الله الزهراني وكذلك السفيره
الفرنسيه هنا ونشاهد هذه اللحظات اوكي
كنس اوكي
فرحتها هذه السيده وهي سيده
من السودان تعبر عن فرحتها بوصولها وهي
التي كنا نتحدث عنها وهي تعمل في السفر
كانت الرحله ممتازه ممتازه الحمد لله انك
تعملين في السفراء الفرنسيه في الخرطوم
كيف يتم عمليه الاجلاء ووصولك هناك بكل
سهوله السفاره الفرنسيه السفير الفرنسيه
نسقت مع
السفيره الهندي وتم اجرائها عبر
امورك صحتك عافيتك ما هو حال الخرطوم
صعب شويه دعواتكم للخرطوم شكرا شكرا لك
اذا هي تتحدث عن سلامتها وعن ايضا كيف تم
تسهيل مهامها وايضا مهام خروجها والوصول
على
نذكر هاني بالحدث الذي نتابعه اذا الان
على الهواء مباشره وصول طائره هنديه من
السودان وصولها الى جده بالتحديد الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه حيث تسهل
السعوديه وتساعد في اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
هذه واحده من عديد الرحلات البحريه
والجويه كذلك التي نسقت فيها السعوديه
واستقبلت فيها الرعايه الاجانب واخراجهم
من السودان واستضافتهم في السعوديه ومن ثم
عودتهم الى بلادهم هاني كما تفضلت يعني
هذه الطائره فيها عدد كبير من الجاليه
الهنديه التي كانت موجوده في السودان ولكن
فيها ايضا بعض السودانيين
نعم
هي طائره عسكريه هنديه في هذه الطائره
تحمل 123 شخص 23 وثلاثه اشخاص هم من
الجنسيه السودانيه الذين كانوا يعملون كما
ذكرت في القنصليه الفرنسيه وكانت السفيره
الفرنسيه في استقبالهم وايضا المئه وعشرين
المتبقون هم من رعايه الهند طبعا اليوم
بالنسبه لمدينه جده واختيار ايضا كمنطقه
او مدينه
كي تسهل عمليه او تسهل عمليه وصول الرعايه
سواء من الجاليه الهنديه او كذلك الجنسيات
الاخرى يعني كنا ايضا العربيه كانت تواكب
خلال الايام الماضيه
عمليه الاجلاء سواء عبر السفن البحريه او
كذلك عبر الاسطول الجوي او الجسم الجوي
وايضا عبر الثلاثه مواقع وهي قاعده الملك
عند الله الجويه التي نتحدث فيها وكذلك
ميناء جدا اسلامي وايضا قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه هذه المواقع هي في مدينه جده هي
مجهزه وايضا موجوده من اجل استقبال كافه
الرحلات سواء كانت هذه الرحلات هي
العمليات اجلاب تابعه للقوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه او ايضا للقوات الجويه
الملكيه السعوديه او ايضا للفرقاطات
العسكريه من دول اخرى او للسفن التجاريه
التي تقوم باجلاء رعاياها كنا ايضا نواكب
عمليه اجلاء لبعض الرعايه من الصين وكذلك
من بعثه الامم المتحده عبر الفرقاط
الفرنسيه لورين وكذلك اليوم في صباح اليوم
كان هناك سفينتين عسكريتين صينيتين وصلته
وتحمل على متنها اكثر من 670 شخص وكانت
هناك ايضا فرقاطه عسكريه
هنديه وقفت في ميناء جده الاسلامي وتعمل
على متنها 1995 الان هو الجسر الجوي
ونشاهد عمليه استمرار نعم السعوديه ساعدت
اذا في اجلاء الالاف من الرعايه الاجانب
من السودان سواء بحريا او جويا هل نعرف
اذا كانت يعني يعني جهود الاجلاء هذه
ستستمر عبر السعوديه والى متى
عمليه نجلاء مستمره واضح جدا يا صهيب من
خلال ما عمليات الرصد التي كنا نواكبها
ونقوم بتغطيتها في بدايه عمليه الاجلاء
كانت مقتصره على سفينه ثم او سفينتين وبعد
ذلك تبعها ثلاثه سفن اليوم هناك ثمن سفن
ونتحدث عن عشرين طائره اذا هناك المزيد من
الرعايه والجاليات الموجوده في السودان
ايضا في الجانب الاخر كنا نتحدث ايضا مع
الرعايه الذين يصلون وكنا ناخذ معهم بعض
المشاهد وبعض الاحاديث والاعداد الموجوده
التي يشاهدونها المعظم قال انه يغادر
يوميا الف وياتي الف اخرون مكانهم اذا
العدد هناك بالالاف نستطيع ان نقول ذلك
ويعتقد ان عمليه الاجراء سوف تستمر لان
ايضا بعض القنصليات غادرت القصريات لبعض
البلدان غادرت واضطرت الى مغادره الى برج
سودان من اجل انهاء اجراءات رعاياها
السفير الفلسطيني مثلا تحدث ان تسعين
بالمئه من الجاليه الفلسطينيه غادره
السودان وهي تتواجد في جده السفير او
القنصل العام الاندونيسي تحدث ايضا
للعربيه ان ما وصل العدد الموجود في
السودان اكثر من الف شخص من الجاليه
الاندونيسيه ومن الجنسيه الاندونيسيه غادر
غادر منها
783 وتبقى الدفعه الاخيره سوف تاتي عبر
جسر جوي ايضا بالنسبه للجاليه النيروبيه
وايضا هناك اكثر من
2600 شخص من يوروبيه ما زالوا عالقين هناك
في السودان اضافه الجنسيات الاخرى عمليه
الجنسيات هي بالالاف بحسب شهود عيانه بحسب
ما تحدثوا لنا في هذا الامر لا ننسى ايضا
ان ايضا استمرار الجسر الجوي وكذلك الجسر
البحري وايضا العمليات الاجرام مستمره
طالما ان
المنافذ التي وفرتها السعوديه سواء
المنافذ البحريه او الجويه هي مفتوحه كافه
البلدان نعم اعود استفسر لو سمحت يعني
السعوديه تقود هذه الجهود الانسانيه يعني
منذ بدايه الازمه وبمجرد يعني كان هناك
مجال لاخراج العالقين في السودان
لا اعلم اذا كان هناك الان تصريح
[موسيقى]
اذا نشاهد الشكر اذا الطاقم السعودي لطاقم
الطائره الهنديه تفضل لهاني
اليوم
اليوم كانت العمليه اجلام في الفترات
النهار وعمليات الاجلاء بالنسبه للجسر
الجوي الذي
القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه وتحديدا
عبر قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه كان هناك
يوم امس عده طائرات عسكريه تنقل رعاياها
من السودان الان نشاهد طائره عسكريه تنقل
رعايه من الهند ثاني نتحدث عن عمليه
التسهيلات التي قامت بها قاعده الملك عبد
الله من اجل اجراء رايه
هؤلاء البلدان طبعا مثل ما تكلمت انت الان
ومثل ما شفت اليوم او كانت العمليات
مستمره يعني منذ يوم الاثنين يوجد هناك
طائرات مدنيه وبعض الدول تستاجر طائرات
المدينه او تستخدم طائرات مدنيه ودول اخرى
استخدمت طائرات القوات الجويه لكل دوله
مثل الهند تستخدم هذه الطائره طبعا تابع
القوات الجويه الهنديه
عندنا في القاعده هنا الحمد لله وفرنا لهم
جميع الامكانيات من ناحيه الباركينج
الخدمات المطلوبه للاطقم الجويه للطائرات
طبعا احنا حريصين على ان الاطقم الجويه
يعني يجدون يعني الوقت الكافي للراحه
المكان المناسب لتمكنوا من التخطيط الى
المهام القادمه ايضا
ليستطيعوا اداء المهام لانهم يحتاجون
صراحه الى وقت راحه
توفير السكن توفير امور كثيره لهم
بالاضافه الى التنسيق مع الشركات التي
تقوم بدعم ومسانده الطائرات من ناحيه
التزود بالوقود
والكيتنج او التموين الاعاشه وامور اخرى
كثيره حقيقه فالحمد لله يعني بجهود جميع
الزملاء وتعاون الاصدقاء كذلك واطقم
الطائرات القادمه
لاجلاء الرعايه الحمد لله تمكنا من النجاح
تمكنا من الى الان وان شاء الله نستمر في
النجاح حتى نهايه العمليات سعاده اللواء
ركن عبد الله الزهراني قائد قائده الملك
عبد الله الجويه في القطاع الغربي في
مدينه جده تحديدا
بالنسبه للمعلومات التي لديكم مطر بورتو
السودان اليوم يعني بورتسودان كنا نشاهد
طائرتين عسكريتين سعوديتين كانت تنقل بعض
الرعايه هل هو مهيا كمطار عسكري امطار
مدني ايضا هو في الحقيقه المعلومه اللي
عندنا انه مطار مدني
ويعني ليس بحجم المطارات الموجوده لدينا
ولكن الحمد لله كان كافي لاستقبال
الطائرات طبعا احنا
نتكلم مع الاطقم الجويه بعد نزولهم
ونسالهم عن حاله المطار وعن التهديد اذا
كان هناك تهديد او هل في امكانيه لمواصله
العمليات
والحمد لله حتى الان الوضع امن في
بورتسودان حسب التقارير اللي حصلنا عليها
من اطقم الجويه ما بعد المهام الامور جيده
جدا وان شاء الله بامكاننا نحن والدول
الاخرى من الاصدقاء والاشقاء مواصله
عمليات الاجلاء باذن الله تعالى الجسر
الجوي مست
مر من الجسر البحث باذن الله تعالى حتى
انتهاء عمليه اجلاد الرعايه شكرا لك شكرا
لك العفو شكرا لكم جميعا على وجودكم معنا
ومشاركتنا شكرا لك اذا كان حديث اللواء
ركن عبد الله الزهراني وهو قائد قاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه
ان هناك نعم تفضلوا على المقاطعه شكرا لك
وشكرا لسياده اللواء لانه اجاب على السؤال
الذي كنت اريد ان اطرحه عليك هاني عن مسار
التكفل بالواصلين الى جده بعد قدومهم من
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك ولضيفك الكريم
مباشره من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه في
جده
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات